- Hey guys, it's Justine,
and a lot of you have been asking me
if I'll be going to the event tomorrow.
I'm so excited.
Yes, I will be.
If you're watching this,
I'm probably actually
on a plane right now to San
Francisco, actually San Jose,
actually Cupertino but the plane...
I'll be there, and I am excited.
Obviously any excuse to go
to the Steve Jobs Theater is,
I just, I will take it, I will go
because it is such a magical place.
Especially just being
there with other people who
love the same things
that I love, like Apple
and technology and just
getting to see all my friends.
Not only I am super excited
about the announcements,
but it's really fun to get
to say hi to everybody.
So Apple's invite for the 25th
was titled 'It's show time'
and obviously it's no secret
that Apple has been working
on a streaming service, working on shows.
They're putting over a billion dollars
into original content,
which is kind of insane
when you think about
how much money is going
into basically just making content
for us to be entertained to watch.
Just stop and think
about that for a second.
For our entertainment, a
billion dollars is going
into creating things for us to watch.
Either way, I'm super excited about this
and honestly, I would do
anything to have a show
on whatever is this streaming platform.
I've got so many fun ideas,
especially ones that kind
of revolve around Apple,
so I don't really know what type
of content that they're looking for
and that's one of the
things that I'm excited
about this event because I feel like
it'll probably be celebrity driven.
I think they'll probably have a lot
of really cool people out to talk
about the shows that they're working on.
One of the things that
I feel like I've been
hitting recently is subscription fatigue.
I don't really have cable anymore,
but the amount that I
was spending on cable,
I think I'm probably spending double that
on everything that I'm subscribed to,
from Netflix to Hulu to Amazon to Spotify
to Apple Music to various fitness apps
to Peloton to just so many things.
I was going through some
of the apps that I use
and it was like, what?
I didn't even realize some
of these things were
still charging like $1.99.
So if you guys do have
subscriptions to apps,
I would recommend going in
at least every few months
and just checking to make sure
that you're not being charged
for something that you're not using.
There was even a yoga
app that I had signed up
for just to test it but
it wouldn't let me login
without actually subscribing,
and I did this like two months ago.
I didn't even take a single yoga class
and now I'm canceling my subscription.
So it definitely is good to go in
and just kind of assess
what are the things that
you actually use and what do you need.
But of course this is Apple so
whatever they do it's
gonna be super exciting.
I know that the one
original content series
that they did have, that
a lot of people had a lot
of criticism for, was Planet of the Apps.
I doubt that that show
is a good representation
of the shows that they
are currently working on.
It'll be interesting, though,
to see the price bundle.
Like, are they gonna bundle
the streaming service
in with Apple Music, are you
paying a little bit extra,
like if you have Apple
Music can you just add
on the streaming service?
One of the things that's
really cool is this past ES,
Samsung announced that you'll
be able to AirPlay content
to Samsung TV without having an Apple TV,
cause I feel like that
was one little small step
of kind of stepping outside
of the Apple ecosystem
and into mainstream everything else,
which is crazy because even
when I heard that announcement,
I was like, this doesn't feel
Apple-like, what's happening?
But it was also really exciting
because it is something
different for Apple
and I feel like at some
point they are going
to have to do things a
little bit differently
because if they just keep
doing the same things,
they need to continue
to push the boundaries
because it's Apple, it's
just what they have done
and I feel like, at this point,
they've been kind of playing
things a little bit safe.
I'm just waiting for, what is
that thing that they are going
to do that's like, super
aggressive, like, okay, yeah.
I just think back to when
they removed the floppy disks
from computers, when they
removed the CD Drives,
when they removed the headphone jack,
when they removed
basically every single port
from your laptop.
I feel like these are small things.
I'm just waiting for,
what is the next iPod?
The iPod was something that
really revolutionized Apple.
What is the next iMac?
What is the next thing
that they're going to do?
I'm not sure if the streaming
service is that thing,
but I still have my fingers crossed
and high hopes that
whatever that next thing is,
it's gonna be incredible,
and I feel like it's gonna be something
in the health space.
I mean this Apple Watch,
I can't even tell you
how much I love my Apple Watch.
It has made me super aware of myself,
of my heart health, the heart rate data,
I have that up, so I know
what my lowest heart rate
and my highest heart rate is at any point
in the day, I can just look at it.
I'm not even sure what this video was;
I was gonna talk about rumors
but there's really not that
much that you guys haven't
really read or heard before.
No one's really saying
anything that crazy.
There's really no hardware rumors,
there's already the AppleTV
4K that has been released.
I feel like maybe there may be some sort
of refresh or update to that, I dunno.
I feel like there's gonna
be mostly software updates.
I think there's gonna be a bunch
of partnership announcements
of Apple partnering
with other television
companies or manufacturers,
but since they did just
release the new iPad Mini
and the new iPad Air and the iPad Pros
are obviously incredible
to consume content on,
and with the new AirPods
that they announced,
it's just kinda setting
the stage or the platform
for all of us to consume
all of their content on,
and I'm gonna tell you what,
this is just a follow up.
I had an iPad Mini years ago.
Since then, I've always gotten
the biggest iPad possible,
but since I've been using this thing,
I don't care that this is the old design.
I don't care that it has bezzles,
I am still so just
absolutely in love with,
this is the perfect
size, obviously if this
didn't have the bezzles, if
this wasn't all-new design,
yeah, it would be incredible,
but this, it just doesn't even feel
like there's anything here.
There's so much power inside
of this little tiny guy,
but I have been carrying this around
for the past few days and
surprisingly have been using this,
I don't wanna say more than my phone,
but because it has the Apple Pencil,
like I've been taking notes on it.
I was in Uber the other day
and I was drawing on ProCreate,
definitely not my best work,
but I was trying to draw the sunset.
I was mostly just testing
out the Apple Pencil
and I didn't even notice a difference
from using the previous
version of the Apple Pencil.
Obviously you're not gonna
have the gesture control.
I really didn't use the
gesture control that much,
even when I was drawing on the iPad Pro
with the new Apple Pencil,
but I just can't get over this.
Like this really is, if you're looking
for a small, portable,
little, tiny tablet,
like this is great.
My phone is almost heavier than this thing
cause I have this battery case on it.
Anyway, I just wanted to
talk to you guys a little bit
about the event, what
I'm looking forward to,
and just know that I will be there.
So you can follow me on Instagram
and on Twitter if you're not already
and Tweet me some of your predictions.
Are there any cool shows
that you wish Apple would do?
What do you want them to do next?
I don't care, it can be anything,
and what do you think that
that one revolutionary thing is?
Is it possibly an Apple car?
Something in the health care?
I definitely think that
the next Apple Watch
will be something super revolutionary,
whether it's able to
track your oxygen levels,
whether it's able to track
your hydration levels,
I'm not sure, I'm just excited
for whatever it is, even
if it is just an update
to being able to track your heart,
I'm into that as well.
I will see you guys soon.
It's late.
It's 11 o'clock, it's past my bedtime.
I'm gonna go edit this
video and then post it.
I'll see you guys.
Bye!
Oh, I changed this to a nice yellow,
I'll probably change it back to pink,
but it was just the next in line,
so I thought I would try it out.
It matched my iPad.
Is that yellow?
What color is that?
This isn't yellow.
This is papaya.
Huh.
(pulsing music)